pascal pelletier pdg d'une société de
lutte contre les risques incendie il
compte 18 salariés 50 % de son chiffre
d'affaires et fait à l'export sa société
est implantée au maroc et ses débuts ont
démarré au sénégal selon lui se
développer à l'international ce n'est
pas forcément facile très difficile très
difficile d'abord c'est d'avoir ce qu'il
faut c'est surtout ne pas arriver en
conquérant vous savez la france a été
une grande grande nation à l'exportation
était très représentée très
représentative aujourd'hui elle a perdu
de son aura parce que beaucoup d'autres
pays aussi font des sports c'est clair
c'est un combat permanent beaucoup de
modestie une expérience qui a intéressé
la chambre de commerce elle vient de
lancer le club international yvelines
pour proposer des formations aider les
chefs d'entreprise dans leurs démarches
administratives
pour pascal pelletier un accompagnement
indispensable
c'est pas le tout d'aller partout et
nulle part finalement après ce qui est
important c'est la notion économique et
de est de savoir organiser son développe
son développement savoir se faire aider
il ya eu 10 france il ya évidemment la
chambre de commerce via la coface ce
chef d'entreprise a pu compter sur un
suivi individualisé ce qui selon lui lui
a permis un développement exponentiel
aujourd'hui le taux de croissance de sa
pme s'établit entre 25 et 30% par an
dans les yvelines et le val d'oise 4200
entreprises sont exportatrices 400
d'entre elles bénéficient déjà d'un
accompagnement à l'international